el yihadismo sacude de nuevo a somalia
un coche-bomba suicida explotó en un
concurrido cruce de la capital
mogadiscio dejando varios muertos y
decenas de heridos el ataque estaba
dirigido contra el convoy en el que
viajaba un alto funcionario de la
policía que resultó ileso- una tienda y
un pequeño restaurante de aquí quedaron
completamente destruidos después de que
un coche explotara delante de sus
negocios los propietarios no estaban
presentes en ese momento pero tres de
sus trabajadores murieron en la
explosión se trata de la segunda
explosión de este tipo que vive la
capital somalí este mes el grupo
islamista al shabab reivindicó
inmediatamente su autoría
los insurgentes afiliados al qaeda
llevan 14 años lanzando una oleada de
ataques por todo el país para derrocar
el gobierno federal de somalia e imponer
la ley islámica charia al-shabab
controló mogadicio hasta 2011 cuando fue
expulsado por las tropas de la unión
africana pero el grupo todavía mantiene
el control de varias zonas rurales del
sur y centro del país y va conduciendo
hacia el hospital madina de mogadiscio
cerca del campamento de la policía
cuando se produjo una gran explosión
sacudió mi auto porque fue una explosión
masiva que se escuchó en muchas partes
de la capital desde el derrocamiento del
dictador mohamed siad barre en 1991
somalia vive un clima de violencia e
inestabilidad política sin un gobierno
efectivo con parte del país a manos de
milicias islámicas y señores de la
guerra bajo este panorama la nación del
cuerno de áfrica celebrará elecciones
presidenciales en octubre